,
EXCELLENPROBATION REPORTING,
GRIFF.
GRF: FOR MORE ON THIS LET'S
BRING IN TEXAS DEPARTMENT SAFETY
LIEUTENANT CIS OLIVERAS,
LIEUTENANT, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
IT ALWAYS GREAT TO TALK WITH
YOU.
I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH
YOU DOWN THERE IN TEXAS BUT
TODAY IS A PARTICURLY SOMBER
DAY, SOMBER WEEKEND, H IS DPS
HANDLING THE LATEST NEWS.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, GREAT TO BE
TH YOU.
YES, YOU'VE BEEN WITH MEN AND
WOMEN OF TEXAS DPS, NATIOL
GUD, BORDER PATROL AND YOU
HAVEEEN THE GREAT WORK THEY
ARE DOING DAY IN AND DAY OUT TO
BE O THE FRONT LINES BUT WHAT
OCCURRED, OF COUE, ON FRIDAY
WITH OUR NATIOL GUARD SOLDIER
IS VERY TRAGIC.
THE BRAVE SOLDIER, THAT'S THE
TRUE EXAMPLE OF BRAVERY AND
COURAGE BYOING INTO THE RIVER,
DANGEROUS RIVER TRYING TO RESCUE
IMMIGRANTS IN DISESS.
THAT'S WHAT THE MEN AND WOMEN DO
DAY IN AND DAY OUT, NATIONAL
GUARDSMEN.
THEY RK THEIR LIVESES BY BEING
ON THE FRONT LINES NOT ONLY
APPREHENDING CRIMINALS AND
SEIZING DRUGS BUT PERFORMING
RESCUING OPERATIONS.
IT'S A VY DANGEROUS RIVER.
JUST THIS MONTH ALONE 19
DROWNINGS IN AREA.
BILL REPORTED 3 I A SINGL DAY.IO
INTO THE RESCUE IMMIGRANTS THAT
ARE VIOLATING FEDERAL LAW BUT
NONETHELESS EY -- REGARDLESS
PUT THAT ASIDE ANDO RESCUE THEPS
BECAUSE THAT'SHAT THEY ARE
THERE FOR, THEY ARE THEREO
PROVIDE A SERVICE A ALSO TO
PROTT THE STATE OF TEXAS.
GRIFF: LIEUTENAN IN YOUR
OPINN WAS THIS AVOIDABLE,
COD THIS HAVE BEEN PREVENTED
IN SOME WAY?
>> YOU KNOW, GRIFF, IT'S KIND OF
HARD TO SAY, OF COURSE, BECAUSE
WH WE ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
REGARDING IFT'S THE NATIONAL
GUARMAN, BORDER PATROL, DPS
TRPER, THEY HAVE A
SPLIT-SECOND DECISION TO MAKE
OPERATIONS, WHETHER RIVER OR
MOUNTAIN IN WEST TEXAS.
THERE'S REALLY NO WAY TO
DETERMINE IF THI COULD HAVE
BEEN AVOIDABLE.
NOW WE DO KNOW, OF COURSE, FOR A
FACT IF THEREAS MORE EFFECTIVE
BORDER POLICIES THAT WOULD
REDUCEHE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRTS COMING ACROSS THE
DANGERS RIVER.
AGAIN, WE WILL CTINUE TO SEE
THE FL OF IMMIGRANTS COMING
ACROSS.
BILL REPORTED EARLIER THATHERE
ARE IMMIGRANTS COMING ACROSS THN
DROWNIS IN THIS PAST WEEK
ALON BUT, AGAIN, DIFFICULT TO
PUT INTO WORDS ABOUT WHAT TK
PLACE AND, AGAIN, GREAT WORK BY
MEN ANDOMEN, RIGHT NOW WE ARE
USING EVERY RESOURCE A OUR
DISPOSAL FROM U.S. BORDER
PATROL TEXAS GAME, MILITARY
TEAM PERFORMING SEARCH AND
RESCUE OPERATIONS TO RESCUE THE
SOLDIERS AND, OCOURSE, WE WANT
TO EEND OUR PRAYERS ON BEHALF
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFE TO THE FIRST RESPONDERSANDY
DAY AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES TO
PROTECT THE ENTIRE CNTRY.
GRIFF: LET LOOK AT WE CAN,
LIEUTENANT, THE MONTH NUMBERS,
200,021 COMPAREDO 173,277.
WE DIDN'T HILL 200,000 UNTIL
JULY LASTEAR AND LAST YEAR WAS
A RECORD UNPRECEDEED NUMBER OF
APPREHENSIS.
WHEN YOU HEAR TOM HOMAN AND THE
REPORTITH THOSE REPORTS
TALKING ABOUT THE BORDER BEING
OUT OF CONTROL, HOW DO YOU SEE
IT.
IS IT OUT OF CONTR.
>> IT IS.THE BORDER PATROL AGENE
OVERWHELD WITH THE CONSTANT
PROCESSING WITH THE SEARCNG OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMING
ACROSS.
FOR THE FIT SIX MONTHS OVER
1.2 MILLION ENCOUNTERS, THAT'S
NOT ILUDING THE OVER 300,000
KNOWN GOT AWAYS.
THAT'S WHY GOVERNO ABBOTT
STEPPE IN FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING AND TEXAS IS TAKING
UNPRECEDENTED ACTIONIGHT NOW
WITH OPERATION LON STAR AND
ADDITIONAL STATE ASSETS T THE
BORDER TO HELP OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS JUST WHAT WEAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DOINCE THE START OF
ERATION LONE STAR.
OVER 14,000 CRINAL ARRESTS.
OUT OF THAT 12,00 FELONY
ARRESTS, OF COURSE, 3800
CRIMINAL TRESPASS ARRESTS.
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT THAT ARE
CHECOINTS AND PRIVATE RANCHES.
SO WE ARE TRYING TO GAINOPERATIS
BORDER, THE STATE OF TAS IS,
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A PROACTIVE
PLAN IN PLACE AND TRY TO PREVENT
WHAT'S -- WHAT'S TO COME IN MAY
WITH THE CARAVS, THOUSANDS OF
IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE WAITING IN
MEXICO.
WE DO IN THE WANT TO SEE, WE
WANT TO PREVENT WHAT TOOK PLACE
IN DEL RIO LAST YEAR WITH THE
HAITIANS AND WE ARE INVOLVING
BORDER OPERATIONS WITH FEDERAL
PARTNERS AND INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS AS WELL.
GRIFF: DO YOU NEED A LTLE MORE
-- JUST IN THE 30 SECONDS WE'VE
GOT, ISHERE MORE THAT YOUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS, NOT BORDER
PATROL BUT THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE LAWMAKERS IN WASHINGTON
COULD BE DOING TO HELP YOU?
>> WELL, COURSE, THEY NEED TO
TAKE MORE EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES,
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM, ALSO DOOT CANCELITLE
42.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO CANCEL 42
HAVE A EFFECTIVE STRATEGY IN
PLACE SO WE DON'T SEE MASS FLOW
OF IMMIGRANTS COMING ACROSS AND
ALSO WORK WITH OER LOCAL
PARTNERS AS WELL AND ALSO
CONGRESSIONAL PARTNERS AND THEY
COME TOGETHER AND HAVE A PLAN IN
PLACE AND BECAUSE OF THAT T
STATE OF TEXAS HAS TO STEP I
AND DEVELOP SATEGIES TO HELP
SECUREHE BORDER AND HELP OUR
FEDERAL PARTNS.
GRIFF: WELL, WEHALL BE WATCH
IF THEY HAVE THAT PLAN IN PLACE.
MY SOUES FROM TRAVENG TO
MEXICO, A CARAVAN HAS ALREADY
STARTED.
IT'SOT A HUGE ONE BUT IT
STARTED IN TAPACHULA AND MADE
ITSELF TO IXT AND TRAVELING TO
EA